it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games and new releases
and this week you get to be a magic
blasting warlock a brutal may laying
Titan or a freaking teleporting hunter
destiny is finally here blasting on to
last and current gen playstation and
xbox this week everyone's a winner oh my
god that's awesome Oh travel to various
planets killing adversaries and dancing
with comrades in an epic out of this
world adventure you won't want to miss
also hover vehicles become legend
September 90 but the week does not end
with destiny no sir we got even more
fantastic console action with NHL 15 and
it looks fantastic in case we're
wondering this is actual gameplay of
pain being a beast NHL comes out
September knight sabers and blue jackets
fittings and we're not even done yet
let's hear it for sports rod Flint back
when left eye pain iPod let's go MX vs
atv supercross is here with 17
Supercross tracks and up to 12 people in
multiplayer so you can show them what a
winner looks like may not wake up and
more not piss excellence the tail whips
begin September 9th also a unique
hand-drawn game magnetizes its way from
pc to wii u this week with tesla grad
this steampunk-inspired old europe world
contains a young boy with an ancient
tesla mansur technology also known as a
magnet glove to climb the test the tower
and take on the pain tesla stock goes up
September 11
and lastly PC finally gets fable
anniversary with those fancy new
graphics so when you're done with all
the other new releases this week you can
maybe get into this one and don't forget
to check out gamespot com on Monday
morning because as a five a.m. pacific
standard time will be streaming destiny
all day for further details visit
gamespot com release states are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change except for destiny see you next
week